my name is leslie lamport and
i am a computer scientist
which is something that didn't really
exist when i started being a computer
scientist and it took me a while to
figure out that i was one
my relationship with computers began
as a programmer it never quite occurred
to me that i was doing anything
scientific until after i had published
enough papers that
it finally occurred to me
my education was as a mathematician it
was just natural for me to think about
computers as a mathematician
when you write an algorithm you need to
have a proof that it's correct an
algorithm without a proof is
a conjecture it's not a theorem
and
if you're proving things well that means
mathematics
computer scientists tend to think in
terms of programming languages
one of the epiphanies in my career was
the realization that i was not writing
programs as a computer scientist i was
designing algorithms i came to realize
that if i'm not writing a program i
shouldn't use a programming language
people confuse programming with coding
coding is to programming what typing is
to writing
writing is something that involves
mental effort you're thinking about what
you're going to say the words have some
importance but in some sense that even
they are secondary to the ideas
in the same way programs are built on
ideas they have to do something and what
they're supposed to do i mean is like
what writing is supposed to convey
if people are trying to learn
programming by being taught to code well
they're being taught writing by being
taught how to type and that doesn't make
much sense
the best way i have for teaching about
programming as distinct from coding is
to think about what the program is
supposed to do mathematically there's a
very big practical problem with this the
mathematical education in this country
is pretty terrible most people wind up
being afraid of mathematics this is even
senior programmers i've developed a
language called tla plus for writing
down the ideas that go into the program
before you do any coding it's a pretty
hard thing for engineers to get into but
when they do it develops their ability
to think mathematically
a distributed system is one
in which
your computer can be rendered useless
by the failure
of a computer that you didn't even know
existed
non-distributed computing is when
different processes communicate by using
the same memory and distributed
computing means that they're
communicating with one another by
sending messages now my interest in
distributed systems came about by
serendipity i received a preprint of a
paper by robert thomas and paul johnson
who had an algorithm for implementing
distributed databases these are
databases where you could have multiple
copies of the data sitting at different
computers so that programs on each
computer could have rapid access to the
data but they had to be synchronized so
that processes on all the computers got
consistent views of what the data was
i happen to have become quite familiar
with special relativity one of the
things that special relativity teaches
you is that two different observers
have different notions of what at the
same time means
but there's one notion that is invariant
there's a certain notion of one event
happening before another event and that
means that
it's possible for information to be
transmitted from one event to the other
when the information cannot travel
faster than the speed of light
i realized that that notion of causality
was violated by the algorithm of thomas
and johnson it's completely analogous to
the relation in special relativity
so what i did is i wrote a paper that
explained this notion of causality
one could
solve any distributed system problem by
building what i called a state machine
think of it as an abstract computer that
has one thing at a time you make sure
that
all the computers
in this distributed system cooperate
to implement a single
state machine
and that idea has become
fundamental in the way people think
about building distributed systems
i had never even thought about a
distributed system before i wrote that
paper
as i progressed in my career i came to
appreciate the idea of working in
industry that's where most of the
interesting problems that i found came
from you know from engineers having a
problem to solve
it reminds me actually of something that
auguste renoir once said if someone
asked him why he painted outside rather
than in his studio and what he said is
if i were painting in the studio and i
wanted to paint a leaf i would be able
to you know think of only a half dozen
or so different kinds of leaves that i
could paint but when i was painting
outdoors
there were just these millions of
different kinds of leaves that were
there that i could paint from
i found my research the same way that if
i sat down you know and just
you know contemplated my navel and think
about problems you know there's a small
number of problems that i could think of
but there were just scares of them
sitting out in industry waiting to be to
be solved
my favorite of my algorithms is the
bakery algorithm it's to solve the
mutual exclusion problem that is keep
two processes from using the printer at
the same time processes choose a number
based on the numbers that have been
chosen by other processes and use an
algorithm so that the lowest is allowed
to use the printer but what is amazing
about it is it does not make an
assumption
that almost every other algorithm makes
the assumption being that if say i'm
changing my number from 47 to 100
and you read that number you'll either
get 47 or 100 but that algorithm works
even if instead of getting 47 or 100 you
maybe got 4 700 or maybe you got 9999
the algorithm still works
i didn't intend it to i mean i didn't
intend that i just discovered that when
i wrote the proof i never needed to make
the assumption that is just so beautiful
uh
and
you know i'm really proud that
that i
stumbled on it
[Music]
you